recent data indicates that to thrive as
a successful marketer integrating social
media marketing into your strategy is
essential staying informed about the
newest technology for social media
management is very crucial the objective
is to distinguish yourself from
competitors however given the multitude
of social media tools it can be pretty
challenging to determine the best
starting point in this video we will
furnish you with an extensive compation
of the most highly regarded social media
tools for overseeing your marketing
campaigns we will delve into the
features and advantages enabling you to
make well-informed decisions about the
tool that will most effectively enhance
your social media marketing strategy in
20124 now let us discuss our today's
agenda we are going to start our session
with lead generation tools moving ahead
we will discuss about buyer Persona
tools then we will Deep dive into
security tools moving ahead we will also
discuss about analytical tools and at
the end we're going to conclude our
session with the content creation tools
but before we start our session I
request you guys that do not forget to
hit the Subscribe button and click the
Bell icon for further updates if you're
looking to get certified as a digital
marketing professional then you are at
the right place so let's take a small
tool to know what simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing has for you join this course
it is a collaboration with per
University and simply learn you will
become eligible to be a part of puu
university alumini Association you will
get master class delivered by puu
faculty you will gain hands-on
experience in managing your budget in
paid marketing campaigns by isent
digital marketing simulation we will
also help you to build your website and
learn real world Hands-On on digital
marketing techniques you will get master
sessions by meta blueprint trainer there
will be also six credit transfer for the
Purdue online in Ms communication
program you will also be meta certified
digital marketing associate exam voucher
worth of USD
$99 there will be five Capstone problem
statement and 15 plus course and
projects 10 plus case studies from
Brands like Adidas KFC Nike Intel Etc
you will learn via Harvard Business
publishing case studies 35 Plus digital
marketing tools will also help you boost
your productivity with chat gbd and AI
tools like blue willow stable fusion and
well set Labs courses aligned with suit
and SE ranking certification you will
learn using metab business Cod chatbot
there will also be live classes
delivered by industry experts along with
self-based content and finally simply
learns job assist is going to help you
get noticed by top hiring companies
hurry up and enroll Now find the course
Link in the description box in this
video we have made it simple for you by
listing the best social media management
tool for businesses we have picked up
tools from various categories such such
as lead generation tools buyer Persona
tools security tools analytical tools
and content creation tools depending on
your business size you might consider
using more than one so let's start with
the lead generation tools which Drive
traffic to your website and help convert
visitors into loyal customer so one
standout tool is opt-in Monster it lets
you engage at the perfect moment by
creating attractive on the site
marketing campaigns with templates and
campaign Builder precisely by targeting
an easy integration into websites if I
talk about his clients its clients are
hward University then Pine interest then
we have Trip Advisor let's talk about
the pricing it is $9 per month for basic
plan and $19 per month for the plus
version then you have $29 per month for
the pro and $49 per month if you want to
grow if I talk about the rating guys I
would like to give it four out of five
ratings now let's move on and discuss
the next digital marketing tool meet
here raffle press a WordPress giveaway
plug-in that comes up with an easy to
use drag and drop giveaway Builder and
they are ready to use templates it's
designed to help businesses expand their
email list and boost website traffic one
standout feature is the verified bonus
actions rewarding users with additional
contest entries for actions like
following you on social media and
sharing your giveaway it's CL are single
grain marketing school and blogging
wizard if I talk about its pricing guys
raffle press offers a plus version for
$49 per year a pro version for $99 per
year a growth version for
$199 per year or a lifetime version for
$449 per year now let us discuss its
rating if I talk about its rating guys I
want to give it 4.1 out of five now let
us discuss the next lead generation tool
that that is smash balloon smash balloon
is a handy social media tool that lets
you seamlessly embed social media feeds
directly onto your WordPress site this
Nifty feature assists in turning your
website visitors into loyal social media
followers if I talk about its Clans guys
its Clans are Coca-Cola Clorox and if I
talk about its pricing guys smash
balloon provides five distant plugins
with options like $98 per year for
professional version
$198 per year for business version and
$398 per year for the smash version if I
want to give a rating for this digital
marketing tool I would give four out of
five now let us discuss our next lead
generation tool that is TWP tweep your
gotoo tool for boosting your Twitter
followers it identifies users interested
in your topic and engages them actively
to grow your following it offers the
silver plan at $112.99 per month and
platinum plan at
$24.99 per month now if I want to give
it a rating I would give it 3.9 out of
five now let's move on and discuss about
the buyer Persona tools which are
crucial for understanding your ideal
customer one standout tool is soo which
identifies social media users matching
your buyer Persona it tracks social
behavior to categorize users and even
allows you to segment them for more
targeted
approaches if I talk about this clients
guys its clients are extreme networks
and Microsoft now let us discuss its
pricing if I talk about S pricing guys
it's recommended to reach out to soo
directly now let us discuss its rating
its rating is 3.6 out of five now let us
discuss the next tool that is social
Bakers social Bakers is a tool that aids
business into monetizing campaigns by
assessing competitive performance and
leveraging follower data for informed
business decision its client base are
National Geographic hinin and Sony if I
talk about S pricing guys social Bakers
offers the essential package at $200 per
month for 10 profiles or $400 per month
for 20 profile and if I want to give it
a rating I want to give it 3.6 out of
five now let us discuss our next tool
which comes into the security domain
when it comes to securing your business
against threats like hackers and scammer
consider using zero Fox this tool
collaborates with social media platforms
to dedu and Safeguard businesses from
potential hackers additionally it
actively removes offensive content
shielding your followers from scammers
and help preserve your business
repetition if I talk abouts is client
guys it is trusted by Phoenix Suns and
First Command let us discuss it's
pricing for pricing tailored to your
business get in touch with zero Fox
directly that is recommended very much
now guys if I want to give it a rating I
would give it 3.5 out of 5 now let us
discuss our next tool that is last pass
which is a password protection tool
designed to assist businesses in
managing social media passwords it not
only AIDS in creating robust passwords
but also securely stores your existing
passwords in a world if I talk about
clients it is trusted by the New York
Times Fox Business and The Economist now
guys let us discuss its pricing last
pass provides a free version a premium
version for $3 per month a team version
for $4 per month and a business version
for $6 per month I hope so guys you
would have got a brief idea that how
this tool can be useful mostly in the
media industry it would be very good now
guys let us discuss about its rating its
rating is 3.6 out of 5 now let us
discuss another analytical tool which is
Twitter analytics if I talk about guys
Twitter analytics it sounds very
synonymous with Twitter actually it is a
valuable social media tool for
businesses and the best part it it's
free for anyone with a Twitter account
this tool enables you to analyze and
measure your camping's performance by
examining engagement understanding how
users interact with your account and
facilitating adjustments to your
marketing efforts now guys if I discuss
about its client its clients are Fujitsu
and Panasonic let us discuss its pricing
as I have already told earlier that it
is free and if I want to give it a
rating I would give four out of five
it's a very amazing tool and I would
recommend it to you to integrate it with
your business now let us discuss the
next tool this tool is also a very
versatile social media tool designed for
crafting Instagram and Pinterest content
Tailwind empowers you to create visually
appealing social media post schedule
them effortlessly using their Auto
publishing system and optimize for
Maximum Impact if I talk about its
client guys its clients are allora and
also meridith let us discuss its pricing
tailin community of 1 lakh members are
for free or elevate your experience with
the pro version just at $9.9 per month
the advanced version is
$99.99 per month and you can go for the
max version which is
$39.99 per month if I want to discuss
about its rating I would like to give it
3.9 out of five now guys let us discuss
the next two this is also a very amazing
tool and it stand outs as a distinctive
content creation plugin which allows you
to repost previous content across
various social media platforms it
automatically incorporates relevant
hashtag by analyzing old tags and
categories this tool is beneficial for
businesses offering the chance for your
audience to ReDiscover and engage with
older content while also maintaining an
active social media presence if I talk
about its client guys it is trusted by
HubSpot and also buffer if I talk about
its pricing guys you can choose the
plans like $75 per year for the personal
version or $149 per year for the
business version and you can also choose
to $199 per year for the marketer now
guys when the time comes to give it a
rating I want to give it 4.2 out of five
it's a very amazing tool so Guys these
were the top digital marketing tools to
grow business or learn in
2024 thank you guys for watching this
video staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here